all right guys
bang bang i'm super excited i've got
mario here thank you so much for doing
this sir
thank you for having me man i really
appreciate it absolutely let's just jump
right into uh your background before you
started the generalists kind of
walk us through what you did to uh to
get to that point
yeah you know i actually had a pretty
weird path i would say
i uh despite my very american accent i
grew up in england
came to america when i was 18. my
mother's american so i always
spoke an american accent at home but
coming to the states i was very much
like
interested in doing public policy public
sector stuff
and only really fell into tech after
a few different weird career choices so
i went to culinary school i cooked for a
little bit
i worked at a law firm i wrote a lot
working on a novel
and then coming out of grad school
basically went to
a fund called red sea ventures which
does mostly like consumer facing
investing in new york then a stint
operating at a company called
andco and then for the last couple years
have been at a firm called
charge and charge does pre-seed seed
investing
also in new york a little bit more tech
focused and uh
yeah had the chance to work there before
trying to
try to emulate your solo success
so i saw this italian culinary arts
uh on your linkedin and i was like i
gotta ask him about that what was that
that that just
fascinates me uh in terms of it seems
like there's this like creative element
to it
um and uh and a bunch of other stuff so
what was kind of the thought process
there
yeah i mean i always found my main
creative
outlet to be writing growing up so
always was trying to write a novel as a
kid and stuff like that but um
food in my family was definitely a big
thing my father was italian
still a lot of family there and
just really respected the ability to
cook well so when i was sort of
in this period of wilderness after
working at a law firm and realizing you
know
i wasn't going to want to be a partner
at a big firm and then
go try and you know win a congress a
congressional seat
um i decided to go to culinary school
and like test that
out as a different life for a little bit
and was lucky to do it and had a really
good time
absolutely and then talk us through so
you were at charge right
kind of doing what i would consider a
pretty traditional venture capital type
uh job and career path uh and then
you start the generalists and so kind of
how did that begin and
why the um kind of focus uh or
fascination with going out and
doing this yeah i mean charges i think
in and of itself a little bit of a
startup it's a super new
firm um i really went because the
partner at charge a guy called brett
martin
is like this fascinating electric
thinker and just person
and so building with him was something i
really wanted to do and
loved getting to do it but for me
writing like
kept being the thing that i wanted to
spend more time on
so you know i mentioned i spent some
time writing the first draft of a novel
i did that probably in 2013 and then for
the next seven eight years
would wake up early in the morning work
on it for an hour or two
and then go to work um and so always
have this like muscle of trying to write
more
um and realize that i should start
applying it to some
degree at least to the world adventure
in tech and so
starting in august of last year i wrote
this
article about yc and how yc
creates this manufactured urgency that's
really bad for
founders and investors and that was
really prompted because i was talking to
some yc companies
and one of the founders in a linkedin
message was like cool i'm happy to hop
on a call but can you make
uh a decision in 30 minutes i was like
no
of course not like why would you want
someone who could make a decision in 30
minutes
that's insane for a decades-long
relationship
potentially um and that piece like did
fairly well for me at the time um and
really opened my eyes to like
what it is like to share your ideas
publicly
um and bit by bit i just kept doing that
um and that became the generalist it
became like
a product more and more um and as i
started to
see that happen i realized that i wanted
to like give more time to it so
that's the experiment that i'm running
now and
we'll see if i can make it a sustainable
business absolutely
and kind of this tagline of from idea to
ipo right
it's most people would focus on just
early stage or just maybe growth stage
or public companies
you really are trying to span uh kind of
the the full spectrum
of um literally from the earliest days
of a startup all the way to the largest
public companies
why not focus on like one specific part
of business why kind of go after the
full stack
honestly just bad strategy like i should
almost certainly do
one um i've had lots and lots of people
tell them tell me i should but
the truth is the more serious answer is
i think there's a lot of people who
actually love
thinking across that stack and i think
that's more and more common simply
because
tech moves so fast companies move so
fast they're like you can be following a
company one day
and it's ipointing and not that long
from now or it's you know suddenly a
growth stage not that long from now
i also think there's just like a ton of
overlap between
the type of tools that are useful at one
stage or another so
the folks that are looking at companies
uh in the public markets
have some amazing frameworks that
frankly like
i didn't see a ton at early stage
investing levels
um but that i think are incredibly
useful so
my hope is that you know the generalist
can be
a community and a publication for people
that
want to go through the effort of really
learning how to think
about the future and about tech across
that span
and who do you find kind of this is most
attractive for are there certain types
of occupations
um is it a u.s focused audience versus
international like how do you think
about who's actually consuming the
content
yeah so uh i think there's probably a
ton of vcs at least from the emails that
roll in and that's probably just like a
function of my network in reach
um definitely a lot of folks who work in
big tech or or at startups
definitely a lot of folks that work in
finance to some degree or another who
maybe like are in a tmt group
and are interested in what's you know
bubbling under the surface of
of the stuff they usually look at mostly
us from what i can tell and then a big
audience
in india and china and to a certain
extent the uk
got it and when we say big it's nothing
as big like it's big for you for the
record like
i'm at you know 12 000 13 000
subscribers
uh and and so still still very much like
chipping away
how have you grown that so far right
like like what have you done that's been
successful in terms of going from
you know no subscribers to now 12 13
000.
i mean it's the classic startup do
things that don't scale thing
um so you know so many of my early
subscribers were me reaching out to
the vc club president of harvard's group
or you know the dartmouth mba group or
whoever it was and saying
hey this is a free newsletter um it's
read by a bunch of your classmates like
maybe you would like it and maybe you'd
want to
send it out to your group and that like
would get me
10 or 20 new folks uh just with a little
bit of extra effort
and then you know bit by bit i think
honing the sort of content that i became
a little bit better known for um also
helped a lot so
things like the s1 clubs that really had
i think
a clear positioning and were timed
around a specific event often would like
catch on in a way that you know maybe a
piece about a
startup that raised a series a wouldn't
absolutely and so uh recently you wrote
this piece called the six billion dollar
stare uh and you know when i first saw
it i was like oh wow that's like a
pretty good headline i wonder what
that's about i click on it
and then i basically read this like
really horrific uh
kind of telling of a situation you've
been going through recently so maybe
just kind of give us an overview of what
exactly happened
yeah and i will preface by saying i'm
really sorry that
um if my voice shakes a little bit
because this gets me
like i can feel my adrenaline pumping
when i talk about it because it gets me
really frustrated
so apologies on that front but basically
the situation
is that on october 18th
i with a collaborator wrote a piece on
quote-unquote compounders
and compounders are public companies i
guess they could be private companies
too but
traditionally public companies that grow
double digits over an extended period of
time
so an example from the 2010s is netflix
right like
huge amount of growth over this decade
that's a concept that i thought was
really interesting and that
my collaborator had taken a class about
at columbia business school and so we
worked together to give sort of like a
primer on
compounders what they are a few patterns
they might follow a few characteristics
in general i think it's like a fun piece
because we frame it
in the lens of like jay-z's investing
career
and you know wu-tang rap quotes and
stuff like that
but in terms of content it's stuff that
you can
find in a bunch of morgan stanley pieces
two row price pieces
podcasts white papers even like a lot of
it's drawn from something like
investopedia it's really
not uh the most secret sauce that we're
we're sharing but
regardless um the next day i heard from
my collaborator
that a fund he used to work at
contracted for
had ordered him to pressure me to take
the article down
and they did that saying that we had
relied on quote unquote proprietary
information
now i knew that we had not
but i also knew that my collaborator was
in a pretty tough spot
um this is a fund he used to work at
that he was going to rely on for a
reference for
a future job he was out of work at the
time and out of respect for him i said
i'll take it down but let's find a
solution because
i know that we have not done anything
wrong here um
and and i really wanted to find like a
win-win here i was sure there had to be
some sort of misunderstanding
so you know i thought maybe we could do
an interview with someone from this
hedge fund
maybe we could highlight some of their
work um but when sort of i talked to
them
and this partner the next day it became
clear that
they really had taken a pretty hard-line
stance but
also a pretty confusing stance i never
really found out
exactly what parts of the article they
considered proprietary
you know and i really did try and find
out so for example
at one point in the article we talk
about how compounders sometimes follow a
good to great pattern
simply meaning in this in the classic
jim collins sense that
they you know start out good they
undergo some sort of transformation
and they become great um and the partner
i spoke to mentioned
that that was problematic to them and
when i asked like
is it the phrase good to great that's
problematic or the idea that companies
sometimes
improve immediately the response was i
need to get the general counsel involved
and that to me just demonstrated that
there was no
real argument to this and that it was
really bullying
um or scare tactics and so
at that point i really didn't know what
to do i think we sort of brokered
a little bit of an agreement on the or
what i thought was an agreement on the
call which was
delete the whole section about good to
great and something else i just wanted
to be over with it at that point
um but even after we had agreed to that
they then came back the next day um
and said nope you can't even put the
revised version up and parts two and
three of this series that you plan to
write
you also can't write those even though i
mean
they don't even know what's going to be
in them yet but basically they wanted me
to seize the whole project
um and so that was sort of the the
problem
and i'll i'll take a break there um
because i know i've been talking for a
moment
and happy to dive into you know what
came next or anything else
so my whole thing when i was reading
this is just like it seems pretty petty
right in terms of like saying hey we
have
not even ownership of a word uh but an
idea
right and kind of like uh i would think
that if you understand how the internet
works you want as many people writing
about
your ideas as possible and saying hey
like this great idea came from this
person or this group or this
organization especially when it's
something that is kind of
out there and i could understand if it
was like an algorithm or a formula
or you know something that um could give
you a specific advantage but when it was
more of like a
a mental framework right it's kind of uh
i don't know it just seemed very uh out
of the ordinary that somebody would try
to
uh lock something down because
ultimately what ends up happening is
like you get the streisand effect right
where like
now uh there's much more attention on
this there's much more
um kind of eyeballs looking and be like
wait who's the
group that's being petty right and it
just i don't know it seems like a
miscalculation in my
opinion i think it was definitely a
miscalculation i think
it was one individual who
maybe saw something that she didn't like
because you know maybe she felt
ownership over the concept because she
had researched
this herself i mean she clearly i must
i must state very clearly did not invent
it but for whatever reason felt
ownership over it
um made a bad call and then i think just
kept doubling down on it
um and you know i had never heard of the
streisand effect before this happened
but like yes i think that's exactly
what has occurred here yeah and talk a
little bit about
um kind of you write uh
the pieces on sub stack obviously as
you're just starting a business
you've got kind of you know we'll call
them the bully in the room
um in terms of this hedge fund that is
threatening
to use the general counsel and all these
things it feels a little bit like
uh your best defense um or kind of the
best tool in your tool kit really is
uh to just shed light on the nonsense
right and just say hey look if you're
going to be a bully that's fine i'm just
going to tell you when you're being a
bully
and i'll let kind of the market take
care of this because i can't
fight you dollar-for-dollar or anything
like that right
yeah i mean honestly in hindsight that
seems really obvious of like of course
internet's undefeated you know
put the people behind you and share the
facts and people will realize that
this is very very silly and undignified
behavior from
a hedge fund with a great deal of money
um i would say that until i actually
shared the story on friday
i was insanely anxious about this
and how it would go down not that people
would disagree but just that like
maybe no one would care and maybe it
would annoy them more
and like bait them to chase me down
harder
um because i hadn't seen a lot of
behavior that seemed particularly
rational or logical to me at that point
and so i was like it feels like this is
emotionally driven
even pushing a little bit maybe could
just like force them to take this to
another
level but what happened was obviously
the opposite and
you know i still don't know how it's
going to pan out i'm i'm optimistic at
this point that it would just be like
insane for them to keep this going um
but man people came out
in full force shared a million
compounder examples
great resources offered to like chip
into a legal fund
uh you know just unbelievable so
in hindsight like yes that was the only
way to balance the asymmetry
uh was to like bring the people into it
and so i'm like
you know it's always annoying when
people say they're really humbled by
something but like this is one of the
few times where i'm like i really do
feel pretty humbled by this this was
wild and like i feel incredibly grateful
i just love the idea of the internet is
undefeated because i think that is uh is
very very accurate um you also have
written obviously many other great
pieces i don't want to spend all of our
time talking about just that one
um two in particular that i found
interesting was one you wrote about ant
group maybe talk a little bit about kind
of your process why did you write about
this how did you gather the information
and what you learned from it
yeah this was really fun because i um i
like to try and do collaborations as
often as possible
both from a personal learning standpoint
as
well as a strategic one and i'd be
really curious to hear how like
how you think about this but when you
look at the youtubers out there that
scale audience effectively most of them
rely on collabs right like
cross promotion is just so huge for
distribution that it makes sense to do
it um
and so one i like doing it strategically
for that reason
and two there's so many intelligent uh
brilliant people out there who are
carving their own little niche
that as often as i can like i want to
try and find ways where we can
furrow some path together for a piece or
a couple pieces
and so that was the plan with
compounders and it was also what we did
with ant group i worked with lillian lee
who writes a sub stack um called chinese
characteristics
covering tech in china she reached out
about one of my pieces
um asked if you know we could connect we
had a great conversation and
on that call i was just sort of we were
batting around
ideas and since ant was coming up i was
like we should just do a
you know thoughtful teardown of this
that
hopefully can stand on its own um and so
that's what we released today and
and hopefully it's an interesting
breakdown of a generational business
that
we just don't have the likes of in the
us
it's really unique what was the biggest
surprise that you kind of learned more
and more about the business like was
there one kind of takeaway where you're
just like i did not expect this
uh the scale i mean the scale is just
insane uh
the title of the piece is ant group of
financial infestation
and it really feels like that they have
just managed to
both create dominant positions in you
know
individual product lines but also create
this insane scope across
payments insurance credit and so forth
um
and you know when you look at sort of
the transaction volume
of ant versus a paypal it's really like
orders of magnitude higher um and so and
paypal's you know
a behemoth it's a 200 plus billion
dollar company
um and so for ant to have reached the
scale and
and still for i think many in the west
to not recognize that
um was shocking to me yeah the part two
that
is so uh fascinating is like i think in
the united states many founders
um they kind of stay very focused on the
one thing that they're building
uh maybe you could say like a google or
an amazon like they get to the point
where they can kind of
expand past that and you know if you say
what is amazon you describe them as an
e-commerce company now people like ah
kind of right they have all these other
things that they do and they do
very well it feels like ant uh one was
early to that uh but also
two has done it uh in kind of a global
digital scale as well right and so
um i i think that just from the american
viewpoint uh
we just don't understand how important
that company is
um because yeah maybe you could compare
it to like an amazon or something like
that but
uh it just feels like it's much more
ingrained in the everyday person's life
than
than an amazon would be right i think
that's totally right you know it's
by owning the payment channel they're
now able to serve customers in
all of these other ways it's the way
that you check out on taobao
uh when you buy something it's also the
way that you like buy groceries at your
local
store to swipe a qr code um and
you know one of the parts of it that i
really loved is that it really initially
began
as essentially an escrow service for
alibaba
just so that you know buyers and payers
money could be safe until a transaction
was complete
and it happened almost exactly at the
same time as ebay partnered with
escrow.com in 2004
and it's just insane to imagine that
like
these almost exactly similar features
and products
one remained essentially as as small as
it as it always was you know a small
piece of a much bigger puzzle
and one you know got bitten by this
radioactive spider
and morphed into this financial mega
company
um so it's just yeah it's i think it's
testament one to like the jack ma
laddering up of products um as well as
the idiosyncrasies of chinese tech
absolutely another series that you've
been working on is this series around
audience and wealth talk a little bit
about that one and the process behind it
yeah i mean this was really me trying to
figure things out for myself
the generalist is 100 free right now but
as i eventually
realized i will have to make money at
some point i was like cool
what are the models available to me and
who are doing where the people doing
interesting things
so you know everyone knows that there
are ads available
everyone knows that there are
subscription fees available i think
there's this
sort of third wave that's happening that
you're a part of
um which is using your audience to build
ownership
right like now you have your your
rolling fund you're using your power of
distribution
to say to founders hey like distribution
is a really tangible benefit that i can
give you
and honestly is actually quite
differentiated from many vc firms in my
view
like vc firms are speaking the same
language
so often that i think most founders
can't actually tell
what value they bring because they say
you know
we're your first call we're you know
good advice for you we have some
portfolio services
whereas you can say cool but i have like
400 000 people following me on twitter
like
if i tweet about you that's going to
make a difference um and so i think
there are more and more creators like
you
who are able to compete with the best vc
firms at early stage rounds or you know
taking a piece of a later stage round
and building their wealth that way so
one i think that's really interesting
um and then two i think there are a lot
of sort of modified
business models that are happening that
are really worth exploring
so mr beast is a great example right mr
b is a youtuber
who instead of taking ad dollars and
just
giving a casual shout out during a clip
uses those ad dollars as the content
itself the one million dollars that he
gets from the dragon city game
or however much becomes the prize which
he then uses
to bring in all of these other users to
compete
and so it fundamentally changes the
dynamic between
creator audience and advertiser
advertisers suddenly become part of the
content
audience members suddenly become the
content
and it just creates a much more virtuous
cycle where you can start to use
that that growing ad dollars to do
more and more interesting pieces of
content and i think there are lots of
examples of this where
you know there's a lot more we can do as
creators
to change and blur those boundaries in a
way that ends up benefiting
the people who are reading or paying
attention or engaging with us
absolutely and it also feels like um not
only the lines
blurring between kind of the audience
and
the creator but it also feels like who
is a creator is changing as well
right so we've seen obviously somebody
or a company like sub stack be able to
say wait if you're a journalist you're
just as much a creator as
anybody else we've seen youtube take
people uh you know with
all sorts of different interests whether
they're very mainstream or niche
and say you're a creator right and so
talk a little bit maybe about how you
see that evolving
yeah i think we're seeing essentially
the like entrepreneurialization
of the creator um as a as a pathway
so you know whereas someone who maybe
had a very traditional career path in
mind um
you know was going to work at a bank or
a consulting firm and then sort of rise
up the corporate ladder
like so many others we're seeing the
relationship between institution and
individual
untethered unmoored attenuated in some
way
often that's been that's resulted in
entrepreneurship right you're like cool
i'm not going to work at a bank but i'll
start a startup
and raise a couple million bucks and you
know try and grow that
but i think we're seeing that creators
are now a very legitimate pathway
for that sort of ambitious person
who recognizes cool maybe i don't have
one idea
that is a software product that i really
want to build and want to for 20 million
dollars into
uh but maybe i have a passion that i
think is commercializable in some way
um and so i think as a result we're
getting like a different sort
of creator in some fields it's like you
know the business analysts
in our world um who are are excited to
build like a personality business
rather than you know down the
venture-backed route or
you know just start a patreon account
and hope that something's going to
happen for them
absolutely when you think about kind of
the work you've done
so far talk through maybe um what have
you found to be the
hardest parts um of kind of building
this
you know in this unique kind of new
creator or solopreneur type
model the hardest parts
are carving out
time away from it um i think like when
i mean this is this is a very privileged
position but like when you're doing what
you really enjoy doing
and also when you are reliant only on
yourself of whether
it works or doesn't work i think it's
really hard to switch off either because
you're excited about the project you're
working on you want to just keep going
and
you know blaze through dinner and blaze
through bedtime um
or because you're like damn i did not
get
many subscribers this week like this
sucks i need to fix this if i'm gonna
you know get on the trajectory i've set
for myself
um and so yeah i mean you just kind of
live or die by by your own actions in
that respect and so i find that really
hard
um and then there's a bunch of stuff
that like more tangibly
is i think an opportunity for startups
and builders where it's like
man the creator economy gets a lot of
mind share um and a lot of attention
because
obviously that's what it's aimed to do
but the infrastructure is
is quite underbuilt for the most part so
i think there's a lot of things that
people could do to streamline the
creator's life
in a really interesting way i have a
bunch of um
ideas for any builders out there that
want to uh want to work on them i'll
probably share them in requests for
startups or something like that
what's one or two that you're just like
this is a no-brainer every person you
know would go and use it if they built
if somebody built it
well i'm curious if you will agree but
um i would really love
a creator specific um
like man i'm blanking on the world word
not cms what's uh
what does salesforce do oh like a crm
like a crm yeah yeah
yeah yeah took me a minute um yeah a
creator focus crm
that basically aggregates all the data
from every platform where you interact
with people
youtube twitter sub stack etc etc um
can pull out interesting information
about those people so
who's the person who responds the most
who is the person who shares the most
how are people interacting and then
allows you to set up
automations for rewarding or engaging
with those people so you can say
cool the people who always answer the
riddle correctly at the end of the
general list
like i'm going to create a special you
know offer
of the hardest possible riddles for
those people or you know here are the
people who keep showing up to my events
like i'm going to host a private salon
of
just 20 people and do it for them um
and i think there's a secondary element
which is like i think you can also start
to do interesting
things around badging and rewards that
are visible
to say like cool you're one of my super
engaged people like
in the slack channel here's some sort of
visual significance
visual token that i can give you to show
to the rest of the people
um so i would love to see some
exploration around that would you use
that
yeah i i think that they're the big
issue is just
uh i counted one time you know on my
phone alone what are all the ways that
somebody can communicate with there's
like 17 platforms right that includes
you know dms on social media and like
all the sort of stuff
uh and then two is like uh you actually
may not realize especially with like uh
student anonymous accounts on twitter
um or something like that you may not
realize that the same person who's
responding to your email
is that person on twitter so like that's
completely lost to you
um and it is definitely weird when they
think that you know
but you don't know um and then on top of
that like
there's definitely this element of like
who are your kind of
mvp uh consumers or audience right and
you can measure that a whole bunch of
different ways it may actually be
different for you versus me for somebody
else
um but but being able to kind of
identify that
uh and you know treat those people how
uh they deserve to be treated right it's
kind of um
you know the airlines do a great job
with it right where uh if you fly a lot
you get points if you have a lot of
points then you get free flights and you
get a better service on the plane and
you know you can board first and
all of those types of things and so i
think that um you know eventually these
communities will figure out how to do
that
uh right now the people who are doing it
well are literally doing it on
spreadsheets
uh as we know you know being able to
productize what something somebody's
doing on a spreadsheet
has historically proven to be uh quite
valuable
totally yeah i mean even the idea that
like sometimes someone signs up to your
email list that you're like
that person is a g i want to like send
them a personal note or
try and arrange a one-on-one talk with
them but like i mean if you have any
number of people signing up a day
there's no shot you see it yeah i uh i
actually don't look
at who's signing up and uh plana looks
at everybody and uh there's a lot of
people who have signed up
and she's like you know been able to
connect with them or whatever
um and she's always like hitting me over
the head being like you gotta look at
who's signing up and i'm just like
it's like looking for a needle in a
haystack right and uh and for me it's
just
one less thing i need to do every day
but uh it is
it's incredibly valuable so if there was
a way to kind of just surface that
information
uh quicker more efficiently and with
accuracy right that's the other thing a
lot of times like
people have tried to you know rank
social media accounts or something it's
like
sure you can do that but if it's not
effective or accurate then you kind of
lose the value proposition of doing
totally yeah 100 agree so paulina sounds
like she's
much more evolved than us about this
absolutely
what uh what's the one thing that you
can point to so far since you've been
doing this and you're like this is my
favorite part
honestly my favorite part is just that i
like get to write every day as my job
um i am
obsessed with awesome sentences and
beautiful sentences
um like i mostly read fiction uh
non-fiction i think can be awesome it's
just i think i really care about that
part
um and so it gives me insane amount of
pleasure
when i can turn a phrase in a way
even about like a palantir s1 where i'm
like
i'm proud of that like that sounded good
to me um and so
i i feel lucky that i get to work
towards mastery
of that because that's what i'd like to
get absolutely
um before i wrap up where can people go
and find
uh the writing that you've done or find
you on the internet
yeah so readthegeneralist.com is is a
website that you can sign up um
most of the writing is actually on
substack if you search the generalist
sub stack you'll you'll find it
um and then my twitter name is
mario d gabrielli um and
uh yeah would love to to hear from
anyone youtube media
is there another mario out there that
stole uh without a d
ah dude it's an empty account with no
one on it
there's not been one tweet there's zero
people following there's no picture i'm
like
please and i don't even think their
name's mario they're like uh
twitter handle is like mauricio or
something i'm really confused by it
um but yeah unfortunately i can't i
can't seem to get it
if you work at twitter and you're
listening help the guy out come on
do me a favor please i asked the same
two questions
everybody before i let them go uh the
first one is what is the most important
book that you've ever read
oh man i love these questions i ask
these
questions of people too um important is
a good word but a tricky one
i will say that
honestly the most important is probably
uh fantastic mr fox by will dahl
because that was the book which i read
as a child which i was like
man i am obsessed with reading and i
will always be obsessed with reading
um and so i think that like cemented a
love in my mind
whether it was true at the time or not
um
more recently i'd say my favorite books
are invisible cities by italo calvino
which is like every sentence you could
spend an hour thinking about for the
most part
um disgrace by j.m kasia which is an
amazing
account of well sort of not a count a
reflection of apartheid in south africa
and just incredibly written and then i
would say the autobiography of red
by anne carson which is essentially a
prose poem
um and again just like every sentence is
insanely beautiful yeah those are great
suggestions
uh the second question is more fun and
then you'll get to ask me one question
to uh to wrap up uh the second question
is aliens are you a believer
or a non-believer i mean i sort of
suspect there have to be aliens just
from like the
sheer vastness of the universe and the
various goldilocks zones that
you know exist so yeah i don't see why
not
um there was there was a really
interesting tweet
a long time ago from strangely enough
a premier league footballer soccer
player um
which was it's probably likely that we
will interact with aliens technology
before we interact with them because if
you think about it that's almost
certainly how they would interact with
us
and so it's worth wondering like is
there any
technology on earth that could be from
an alien that we're not
familiar with um so yes i think there
probably are
mario don't go down that rabbit hole
with this audience they they will start
tweeting at you all of their uh
speculation as to what the alien
technology on earth is
really dude that's so funny i would love
to hear that
if anyone's got any ideas go ahead and
tweet at them but i'm just warning you
that you're
you're opening up a can of worms on that
one fascinating okay
excellent all right last thing is trying
to ask you right
huh you could ask me one what do you got
put you on the hot spot
okay um what is something that you think
is
important to know about you that is not
visible in early interactions
uh i don't really think there's anything
that is important
uh the thing that i always say to people
i think that it's the most surprising
is they're always asking me like weird
questions like you know what is your
goal what are you optimizing for like
all this kind of stuff
and a long time ago like i reached this
place mentally
where uh it was just look we're all
gonna die
and you get to say you lived a awesome
fulfilled successful life as long as
you're happy
like that's it and that can mean
different things for different people
but uh there's people out there who have
financial goals who have status goals
who have kind of all these different
goals and
that's not to say that those goals are
wrong or bad
it's just like my goal for a very very
long time has been just
be happy and that can take many
different forms
uh but when you can do that like you
kind of just get to say like
i don't care about like all the nonsense
in life um you know
it's like look there's a massive like
political election going on right now
and and
if you go on certain uh tv channels or
on certain social media feeds
it literally looks like people about to
kill each other right like
like they really really disagree with
each other
for me it's like i'm paying attention
right like like it has an
impact but like i'm personally happy and
so regardless of who wins
like they're not going to affect my
personal happiness
right because like kind of i'm in charge
of that and i think like in that's a
really extreme example but like when you
turn over
the ability of whether you're happy or
not to like who the president is or
uh you know somebody down the street or
a co-worker at work or whatever
like you kind of just like lose control
right and
for whatever reason like i've always
just thought about it that way and
uh i think that really surprises people
because they don't expect me to kind of
think that way hmm
can i ask you one more of course if you
could
moderate a discussion or debate between
two people
who would you choose like who do you
want to mostly bounce off each other
so i'm gonna not answer that only
because i probably can't come up with a
good answer but i will tell you
one thing that i've always thought uh
would be really fascinating is
uh to get the two presidential
candidates to sit down
uh long-form discussion like i'm like a
joe rogan style
but instead of being like what do you
think about this topic it's to force
each one of them
to argue the other side that would be
super interesting
like trump explain why joe biden
believes what he believes on health care
joe biden explain why trump believes
what he believes you know around
taxes or whatever and what it forces
them to do
is one uh be able to articulate the
other side's
issue so like you can tell very quickly
like
hey who's paying attention who's
listening right like
have i taken enough time to kind of
intellectually be honest and
and look at both sides or multiple sides
of an issue
and then come to a conclusion right and
then you can almost follow it up with
like okay like why do you disagree with
that
and so i just think that we are in this
world of like
the intellectual debates don't happen
right it's much more like
you know name calling and kind of like
the salacious who can get the headlines
all that kind of stuff
um it happens from both political
parties like i know that everyone wants
like virtue signal against each other
but like
just getting people to sit down and like
have a very deep conversation
uh i always like asking them you know
argue the other side what would change
your mind right you know okay
uh trump you believe x what would it
take to change your mind biden you
believe why what would it take to change
your mind
and you could very quickly i think just
like peel away all like kind of [ __ ]
right and just get to the like hey who
knows what they're talking about and who
has like the
intellectual rigor to actually uh
analyze situations and make sound
decisions
because that's kind of like what we want
in a president
right it's like just somebody who makes
sound or like reasonable decisions
and they don't have to be popular right
like actually most of the more
reasonable decisions are probably not
popular
but i just think that the entire process
as i've kind of been watching this
uh and like really trying to think
through like
why is it broke that's the thing that i
keep coming back to is just like
the entire process is built to avoid any
sort of like
intellectual you know kind of debate
that would
highlight who is a sound reasonable
decision maker and who's not
yeah they're almost incentives to
misunderstand
then rather than to understand and there
is such a weird
human and maybe more in the us than
elsewhere i'm not sure
uh impulse towards thinking changing
your mind is bad
which is like changing your mind is a
superpower
like that's the only way development
occurs but
uh yeah for some reason like even the
notion of a political flip-flopper right
it's like well okay maybe that person
just like changed their opinion that
would be good wouldn't it
like if they changed it based on
evidence that was probably a good thing
yeah and and i think that also uh like
flip-flopping is a great
thing right like there's a good side and
a bad side to it right so like if you're
just simply every time you run for a
political office you're just like
pandering to
one more group or another and like you
constantly change your position but you
can't articulate
why like what was the new information
you received yeah but if instead you say
hey look my entire life i believed x
then i got
pieces of information one two and three
and now i believe why
it's like hey whoa that's a rare thing
like i would love that per like who's
that person um
so i think again it goes back to like
you got to go to like the
the more deep layers of these
conversations
um and the formats are just off right
you know network television is all about
the
you know kind of 60-second what's the
most salacious clip that we can find and
kind of
you know present that kind of keeps
people's attention the debates
you know at this point even with
shutting microphones off and stuff or
just
i mean just not very effective right and
so uh i do think that um
you know kind of going back to like
let's get long-form human-based
discussion like forget your talking
points you know
explain why uh could could do uh the
entire country
you know a pretty good service well said
i'm i think that's a a stirring place to
end
absolutely all right mario listen thank
you so much for uh for doing this
uh best of luck as you continue to build
this and uh
if uh if big large bully corporations
and
hedge funds want to keep being [ __ ]
uh hopefully everyone who's listening to
this can kind of
chime in and provide a little bit of
relief for you so i appreciate you doing
it anyone who's interested
uh go check mario's workout at
readthegeneralist.com
thanks so much man been really lovely to
be here